und jetzt haben sie die volle
aufmerksamkeit herr klein ja sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
bundesregierung aus spd grünen und fdp
hat uns einen haushaltsentwurf 2023 mit
445 milliarden euro ausgaben vorgelegt
445 milliarden euro das sind circa 50
milliarden euro weniger als im laufenden
jahr
2022 aber das liegt ja vor allem darin
dass große
maßnahmenpakete hilfsprogramme die mit
der krise zusammen gegangen habe neben
auslaufen 445 milliarden euro das ist
aber auch deutlich mehr als im vor
krisen jahr 2019 das ist auch deutlich
mehr als alle finanzpläne vorgesehen
haben vor der krise oder auch der letzte
von der großen koalition aus 2021
zwischen 40 und 70 milliarden euro mehr
und das zeigt noch einmal dass diese
bundesregierung unter
bundesfinanzminister
konsolidiert das ist auch richtig aber
dass wir in keinem fall von einem
sparhaushalt reden was der ein oder
andere ja tun möchte liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen in diesem haushalt stecken
58,4 milliarden euro investitionen 18,7
milliarden euro kommen noch mal für
militärische beschaffungen oben drauf
und wir investieren in den klimaschutz
in digitalisierung in bildung und
forschung und in die
verteidigungsfähigkeit dieses landes was
in diesem haushalt aber auch drin steckt
sind die enorm gestiegenen zinsausgaben
2021 waren es noch 3,9 milliarden euro
zinsausgaben nächstes jahr plant der
bundesfinanzminister mit 29 milliarden
euro und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das zeit noch einmal mehr es war gut
gott sei dank haben wir nicht auf die
reihe weber gehört die uns weitere
staatsverschuldung aufgrund von
niedrigen zinsen niedrig oder
negativzinsen schmackhaft machen wollten
gott sei dank im sinne von zukünftigen
generation
und deshalb ist es auch um so wichtiger
dass dieser haushaltsentwurf die
schuldenbremse einhält ja die
schuldenbremse steht in der verfassung
das muss man ja leider in diesem haus ab
und zu noch mal erinnern daran erinnern
aber ist es vor allem ein instrument der
generationengerechtigkeit
diese schuldenbremse art mit mit der
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung mit sie
gibt uns die möglichkeit auch auf
schwierige wirtschaftslage zu reagieren
auch auf technische rezession im übrigen
und sie ermöglicht in
ausnahmesituationen zu agieren sie
kennen das aus den letzten jahren aber
sie macht vor allem eins sie
gewährleistet die handlungsfähigkeit der
bundesregierung und dieses landes um die
dauerhaften herausforderungen den
dauerhaften herausforderungen gerecht zu
werden da reden wir über den
demografischen wandel da reden wir über
die chancengerechtigkeit in der bildung
den sozialstaat aber vor allem auch um
das thema klimaschutz das sind
dauerhafte aufgaben die sich in diesem
13 haushalt auch wieder finden und diese
dauerhaften aufgaben werden wir nur
gerecht werden können lernen wir auch
finanzielle solidität setzen die dass
diese bundesregierung tut liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
unsere devise darf nicht sein dass wir
die probleme unsere probleme mit dem
geld zukünftige generationen lösen
sondern das müssen wir schon aus eigener
kraft schaffen
die schuldenbremse aber auch ein
instrument um die inflation zu bekämpfen
und dafür haben wir ja noch bausteine
auch in
entlastungspaket 3 eingebaut die kalte
progression wir haben aber auch
bausteine eingebaut wie einmalzahlungen
wie die absenkung der mehrwertsteuer auf
gas um auf die aktuelle lage das
aggressive vorgehen von vladimir putin
zu reagieren aber zu weit gehört auch
wir können nicht alles abfedern was bei
dieser energieproblematik entsteht wir
wollen not lindern und wir wollen
insolvenzen verhindert und wir wollen
dass strom und gas verfügbar und
bezahlbar und der sack ist das liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen um so
beängstigend wenn der ministerpräsident
des größten bevölkerungsreichsten
bundeslandes diese hilfen den menschen
in diesem land nicht zukommen lassen
will das ist ein skandal wenn er diesen
fragen stellt
zum bergen für dieses paket starke
schultern müssen in der krise auch mehr
tragen die länder haben starke
schuldig punkte zum schluss
die bundesregierung hat einen guten
haushaltsentwurf vorgelegt aber es gibt
keinen grund diesen entwurf noch besser
zu machen und ich freue mich auch die
haushaltsberatung
soweit karsten klein denn hier natürlich
angekündigt hat es gibt noch beratung
das hier ist die erste lesung zum
entwurf des
haushaltsplanes und danach geht es da
noch unter anderen in den bundesrat und
auch in den haushaltsausschuss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bundesregierung ich möchte noch einmal
darlegen was uns als cdu csu in diesem
haushaltsdebatte wichtig war uns ist
wichtig dass wir alle maßnahmen
ergreifen um inflation energiekrise und
die kommende wirtschafts und finanzkrise
zu bewältigen die bürgerinnen und bürger
zu entlasten und die wirtschaft zu
stützen das ist für uns die hauptsache
wenn man
sich nun ihr drittes entlastungspaket
anschaut das liegt ja bisher nur als
pressemitteilung vor eigentlich ein
unding wenn man sich dieses
entlastungspaket anschaut ist klar dass
vor dem mittelschicht nichts drin ist
die mittelschicht schaut mit ihnen in
die röhre und auch die firmen schauen in
die röhre es dieses paket ist wieder
nicht auf der höhe der zeit und wieder
nicht auf der höhe der probleme nach dem
was ihre pressemitteilung uns mitgeteilt
hat fällt dieses dritte entlastungspaket
durch mir hat ein vater geschrieben der
sohn machte eine ausbildung in der
gastronomie verdient 1200 euro und hat
jetzt den abschlag fürs gas erhalten
580 euro im monat mit der miete macht
das zusammen 1000 euro die
einmalzahlungen diese vorschlagen lösen
das problem überhaupt nicht und helfen
auch nicht wirklich ein anderer fall ist
eine große firma bezahlt bislang 30
millionen euro für gas im monat 30
millionen im monat jetzt 160 millionen
euro es gibt kein geschäftsmodell her
wir machen uns alle große sorgen auch
den arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
helfen ihre 200 oder 300 euro
abschlagszahlung nicht sie sind nicht
auf der höhe der probleme und das ist
für uns als cdu csu ein großes problem
weil wir sehen dass sie mit dass sie
keine antworten auf die wirklichen
probleme dieses landes haben auf die
ganz akute krise
profil an und setzten wenig um beispiel
energiekosten dämpfungs programm das
sind 3200 anträge gestellt nur 24 24
sind davon bislang positiv beschieden
übrigens erlaubt dieses programm nur
ausgleich für kostensteigerungen bis
maximal zwei millionen euro wichtig für
den mittelstand aber da gibt es noch
einen großen eine große kluft ein großes
spalt die nicht bedient ist stattdessen
hören wir für symbolpolitik viel klamauk
viel selbstlob und ziemlich viel
unsägliche propaganda die mich empört
weil sie die sorgen und nöte der
menschen nicht ernst nehmen wann fangen
sie endlich an zu arbeiten
soforthilfe ist möglichst sofort hilfe
ist nötig dass sie sind am ziel regieren
das ist jetzt wirklich dumm gelaufen
dass sie regieren sie müssen die
antworten finden wir brauchen hier
schnellstens gesetzentwürfen und
wirkliche unterlagen einmal mehr haben
wir jetzt drei tage lang einen
haushaltsentwurf diskutiert der
makulatur ist in dem die wesentlichen
dinge wieder nicht drin stehen ich
empfinde es als beklemmend dass wir das
getan haben ich empfinde es als
beklemmend ist dass sie am sonntag vor
den haushaltsberatungen ein
entlastungspaket vorstellen dass wir
nicht besprechen können dass im haushalt
massiv verändert dass wir nicht
besprechen können weil es wieder nicht
es tut mir leid ich kann mich übrigens
auch nur wundern und und über die
koalitionsfraktionen sie bejubeln sie
bejubeln einen haushalt der hinfällig
ist ziel bejubeln ein vorgehen der
regierung dass diesen deutschen
bundestag riskiert dass den deutschen
bundestag nicht ernst nimmt ich habe das
schon beim letzten mal gesagt sagen sie
wollen sie die texte vorlegen sagen sie
auch die länder mitmachen über deren
köpfe sie ja einfach bestimmt haben und
sagen sie auch wenn sie den bürgerinnen
bürger endlich den über gewinn
zurückgeben denn der finanzminister an
der zapfsäule und andere gas wir den
hohen preisen erzielt uns ist wichtig
spieler mit zu erhalten für künftige
haushalte deswegen reden wir auch über
die nettokreditaufnahme das hat gestern
der kollege haase getan die rechnungshof
spricht der rechnungshof spricht frau
kollegin von einer versteinerten
finanzlage des bundes in seiner analyse
der schuldentragfähigkeit und rechnet
vor die netto kreditaufnahme liegt
tatsächlich bei 78 milliarden und eben
nicht bei 17 milliarden wie uns der
finanzminister gestern wieder in einem
alten manuskript versucht hat zu
verkaufen 78 milliarden und nicht 17
milliarden jetzt hatte kollege klein ja
ganz tolle dinge heute von sich gegeben
in sachen schuldenbremse
da glaube ich haben sie die
unterstützung der union voll hinter sich
aber wenn man sich in die
koalitionsreihen wie sieht es glaube ich
schlecht aus wo steht die koalition bei
der einhaltung der schuldenbremse
tatsächlich wir können nur sagen nachdem
was wir hier sehen sie stehen halt nicht
dahinter es wäre auch wichtig dass der
finanzminister vielleicht seine ideen
noch mal noch einmal bekräftigt das
letzte mal hat er gesprochen über
beschleunigung von planung und wir
wissen alle dass unser land unabhängig
davon wer regiert an dieser an der frage
von planungen und langen verzögerungen
krankt letztes mal hieß es es gibt eine
arbeitsgruppe wo ist diese
arbeitsgruppen wo sind ergebnisse ich
glaube dass wenn man nicht mit
schlagzeilen regiert sondern mit
seriöser politik dann muss man hier von
dem deutschen gutes darlegen was man
sich vorstellt und nicht nur vor der
presse und jetzt komme ich beim bund ist
das bundesfinanz kriminalamt des
bundesfinanz kriminalamt hatte vor der
presse vorgestellt und hier mit keinem
wort wie kann so etwas sein wie kann es
sein dass wir über diese dinge hier
nicht sprechen und die dinge und die
wesentlichen inhalte aus der presse
entnehmen müssen ich war übrigens nach
15 jahren betrugsbekämpfung auf
europäischer ebene nicht auf die idee
kommen dass in diesem land gehörten
fehlen ämter fehlen hier fehlen
kompetenzen für die entscheidenden dinge
ich möchte ihnen sagen
wenn man ihn kommen sie zum schluss wenn
man sieht wenn man sieht was krise meist
in der krise zeigt sich wer ihr
gewachsen ist die union hat seit dem
bestehen der bundesrepublik gezeigt dass
wir der krise gewachsen sind dass wir
mehr können als schuldzuweisungen von
ihnen habe ich in dieser woche nur
schuldzuweisungen gehört da gibt es noch
ganz viel luft nach oben bei der frage
wie man dieses land aus der krise führt
wie man diesem land und seinen
bürgerinnen und bürger am besten hilft
danke herr präsident
soweit die kritik von ingeborg gräßle
hier in der schlussrunde zum
haushaltsgesetz 20 23
ich war jetzt zweimal höflich aber ich
werde demnächst die redezeiten wie der
exakt einhalten und zwar gegen wir
jedermann und jederfrau und jeder person
nächste redner die ankündigung von
bundestags vizepräsident wolfgang
kubicki und das heißt in seinem fall oft
dass das mikrofon abgestellt wird achim
post spricht jetzt für die spd fraktion
erst der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
präsident liebe kolleginnen kollegen
meine damen und herren wir
dürfen und das ist das gute frau
kollegin in diesem hause über alles
reden und wir reden über alles ich habe
die ganze woche verfolgt wie die
kolleginnen und kollegen in diesem hause
wiesen haushaltsentwurf besprochen haben
und ich finde dass sie sich alle fast
alle sehr viel mühe gegeben haben diesen
haushalt sehr ernsthaft diskutiert haben
sehr ernsthaft geprüft haben wir haben
kontrovers diskutiert wie haben
teilweise sehr heftig diskutiert und
ehrlich gesagt darauf bin ich stolz dass
es in diesem lande möglich ist und
weiter möglich sagen die athleten
und das ist dringender denn je denn wir
führen eine haushaltsdebatte in zeiten
des krieges und der krisen sich
überlappender krisen putins brutaler
angriffskrieg die sich zuspitzende
klimakrise und corona das nicht weg ist
weil wir uns wünschen dass es weg ist
das heißt wir haben eine menge zu tun
und wir alle wissen und das haben die
meisten auch gesagt das hat auswirkungen
auch auf uns auf die bürgerinnen und
bürger auf die beschäftigten auch die
betriebe auf die sicherheitspolitik der
bundesrepublik deutschland auf unserer
energieversorgung
und deshalb muss ich eins sagen nicht
alle haben sich an dieser ernsthaften
debatte beteiligt in dieser woche
es gab eine fraktion die hat mal wieder
ein lied gespielt dass wir alle kennen
seit vielen vielen jahren das lied heißt
deutschland geht unter erst wegen des
euro dann wegen corona dann wegen
maßnahmen die wir jetzt zu russland
machen irgendeinem neuen grund gibt es
immer und ich sage ihnen eins
deutschland wird nicht untergehen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen denn
deutschland ist stark sozial und
demokratisch
und dann muss ich mal sagen diese
bundesregierung dieser
bundesfinanzminister wir haben einen
regierungsentwurf vorgelegt über den es
sich lohnt zu reden wir haben ein
entlastungspaket vorgelegt war dass es
sich lohnt zu reden und wir werden eine
politik betreiben überdies sich weiter
lohnt zu reden die krisen reaktionsfähig
ist und die in zukunftsinvestitionen
denkt und zukunftsinvestitionen tätigt
wie noch nie zuvor in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und deshalb
muss ich mich schon
wundern
dass sie liebe kolleginnen kollegen von
der cdu csu weiter versuchen die
schwäbische hausfrau zu spielen das ist
sehr ehrenhaft und gleichzeitig eine
mehrausgabe nach der anderen fordern wie
das zusammenpassen soll ist mir
schleierhaft
sie fordern
die gasanlage zurückzunehmen das kann
man fordern bedeutet für den
bundeshaushalt - 34 milliarden euro sie
fordern auf die rücklage zu verzichten
das kann man fordern bedeutet für den
bundeshaushalt 23 40 milliarden euro
weniger und wenn ich das alles
zusammenzählt und die zugspitze angucke
was sie da beschlossen haben da kommen
aber locker nochmal mindestens 40
milliarden dazu also alles in allem mehr
als 100 milliarden ich kann ihnen nur
sagen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
der weg vom kanzleramt ins
wolkenkuckucksheim war verdammt kurz mal
hinten
und dann gibt es noch was man darf man
darf in einer haushaltsdebatte darüber
einnahmen reden über die einnahmeseite
das ist erlaubt das verstößt nicht gegen
das grundgesetz
und diese ampel koalition macht
vorschläge wie die einnahmeseite weiter
gestärkt werden kann wie könnten die
kennen sie alle die politik starke
politik gegen geldwäsche
globale mindestbesteuerung ja los geht's
genau das machen wir alles und diese
ampel ist der garant dafür dass wird die
dinge die lange liegen geblieben sind
endlich anpacken liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und zu europa
weil darüber müssen wir reden zu europa
die bundesregierung ist der garant dafür
wie viele bundesregierungen vor ihr wie
viele bundesregierung vorher dass
deutschland stark bleibt und europa
stärker wird liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen denn nur zusammen kriegen wir
das hin nur zusammen kriegen wir das hin
und deshalb muss ich mich schon sehr
wundern dafür braucht man pro
europäische regierungen dafür wollen wir
nicht nur eine starke kommission oder
eine starke kommissionspräsidentin
sondern pro europäische regierungen und
nicht weniger in zwei wochen wird in
italien gewählt vor der tür stehen dr
mussolini eine koalition angeführt von
george clooney eine rechtsextremisten
von salvini eine rechtspopulisten
unterstützt von berlusconi gestärkt von
manfred weber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der fraktions und parteichef
der svp ihre parteien familie ich bin
erschüttert dass eine pro europäische
partei die cdu zu ross zulässt und
deshalb unterm strich und am strick
diskutieren wir weiter ernsthaft auch
sehr kontrovers auch wenn es auch wenn
es weh tut auch wenn es ihnen weh tut
die dinge um die es geht denn dieser
bundeshaushalt dieser entwurf ist eine
gute grundlage
es ist nicht das ende der debatte ist
der anfang der debatte die vogue regeln
schönen dank herr
ist nicht das ende der debatte dass es
klar hat hier auch im post gesagt denn
wie gesagt gibt es noch weitere
beratungen im haushaltsausschuss im
bundesrat unter noch hier
[Applaus]
herr präsident wir haben in dieser woche
nun schon einiges über die
schwachstellen des haushalts gehört aber
viel schlauer sind wir nicht geworden zu
den großen rätseln gehört immer noch wie
die ampelkoalition ihr mythenumrankte
entlastungspaket den finanzieren will
oder wie sie die angekündigte strompreis
bremse operativ bekommen will wenn die
betroffenen stadtwerke die daten dafür
noch nicht einmal haben und das auch
ganz laut sagen ohnehin löst nichts
davon die
energieprobleme ursächlich es wird
einfach nur sozialistisch
planwirtschaftlich umverteilt
wissen sie eigentlich dass ist die
mittelschicht das alles bezahlen soll
bald gar nicht mehr geben wird ja herr
post wenn sie das wie eben geschehen ins
lächerliche ziehen dann zeigt das
einfach nur wie unglaublich arrogant die
spd und wie weit entrückt sie von der
mittelschicht inzwischen geworden ist
die insolvenzwelle ist schon unterwegs
und dennoch unterstellt der
regierungsentwurf ernsthaft im jahr 2023
wieder überschüsse im haushalt der
bundesagentur für arbeit und eine
rückzahlung der mittel in den haushalt
also die weltfremd kann eine regierung
angesichts einer direkt vor der tür
stehenden schweren wirtschaftsdepression
deutschland sein wie fakten resistent
ein fdp finanzminister gegenüber der
realität
anstatt die probleme dieses landes an
der wurzel zu packen regieren filz und
ideologie der korona minister lauterbach
twittert ernsthaft zitat den größten
solidarbeitrag zur krankenversicherung
leistet die pharmaindustrie ihre umsätze
steigen stark
die fakten dazu hatte das mit den
umsätzen stimmt aber die weiteren fakten
bei kaiser wurde bestens verdient hier
forderte der bundesinnenminister jedoch
keinerlei über gewinn steuerte er macht
stattdessen eine dauerwerbesendung für
pfizer packs sowie die gkv dagegen
benötigt 2023 wegen der verheerenden
corona maßnahme folgekosten ein
bundeszuschuss von 17 milliarden euro
und mit dem angekündigten
solidarbeitrag der firma konzerte von
einer milliarde euro hätten ja hätten
diese pharmakonzerne gerade mal fünf
prozent ihrer gewinne abgegeben und
selbst diese milliarde wurde am ende
entgegen lauterbachs lügen tweet wieder
zurückgenommen ganz zufällig entspricht
diese nun felde milliardär euro die
halter bach seine pharmafirmen erspart
hat genau dem darlehen das der bund nur
neuerdings der gkv aus dem haushalt
gewähren muss das lässt einen doch
sprachlos zu rücken
aber reden wir auch ein wenig über dem
grünen filz wenn die radikale klima
sekte aufstand der letzten generation
das sind die die sich immer wieder an
auf die autobahn kleben tatsächlich
hunderttausende steuer euros aus dem
wirtschaftsministeriums etr bekommt dann
ist auch das ein skandal
auch wenn das wirtschaftsministerium
offensichtlich nicht vertreten ist heute
es bleibt ein skandal
gleiches gilt
gleiches gilt wenn eine grüne klingel
ngo namens zentrum liberale moderne
unter anderem mit einer auftragsarbeit
für das kanzleramt namens gegneranalyse
mehr als eine million euro erhält um die
opposition im letzten jahr beobachten
und verteidigungsstrategien aufzuzeigen
grüne ngo allerdings arbeiten für das
damalige schwarze kanzleramt und nicht
zu vergessen die zitat leuchtturm
initiative des
entwicklungshilfeministeriums und der eu
damit stärkung der bürgerbeteiligung an
guter regierungsführung in laos und wem
dieser imperialismus im rahmen der
agenda 2030 der un als begründung immer
noch nicht genügt der sollte im
projektbericht schauen und dann erfährt
er dass es dabei auch um die vernetzung
und beteiligung aller gesellschaftlichen
gruppen geht wobei auch immer in jedem
fall aber unter expliziter
berücksichtigung aller 60 geschlechter
identitäten und selbstverständlich bei
zitat inklusion von transgender personen
also genau das was das entwicklungsland
laut so braucht deutsches steuergeld in
allerbester verwendung
in deutschland und bei uns als auch
verweigert das finanzministerium dagegen
den menschen jede inflationsrate
erhöhung des steuerlichen
existenzminimums die afg fordert hier
seit monaten eine erhöhung auf 12.600
euro
warten dass man für deutsche verbraucher
gibt es stattdessen die gasanlage mit
den faktisch zwei großen gast einkäufern
dieses verzockt haben seit heute ist es
noch ein dritter auch der wirt
milliarden brauchen und die werden
gerettet der eigentliche finnische
konzern juni per für den steht der
finnische staat nicht gerade der
deutsche bürger rettet ihn nur dann
könnt ihr mir das aber auch so gestalten
dass das wenigstens auf kreditbasis
geschieht so dass juniper die über 20
milliarden die es letztlich aus der
gasanlage erhalten soll in ruhigeren
zeiten wieder zurückfahren muss es kann
nicht sein dass hier wieder einmal
gewinne bei wenigen konzernen
privatisiert die verluste aber über alle
steuerbürger sozialisiert werden letzte
satz gewinnt
die fdp fraktion wird zu diesem thema in
der nächsten plenarwoche eine debatte
erzwingen sie ist überfällig vielen dank
peter böhringer könnte ich das an und
wenn die jetzt vom wirt übertragen gegen
auch natürlich ohne höhn spricht jetzt
bis 90 kg
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
diese erste haushaltswoche diese erste
lesung hat sehr deutlich gezeigt die
rahmenbedingungen mit denen es diese
regierung zu tun hat sind wahrlich
herausfordernd und nun schauen wir ja in
der schlussrunde auch immer so ein
bisschen auf die vergangene woche zurück
ich habe die debatten zum haushalt sehr
aufmerksam verfolgt und ich muss schon
sagen in richtung der union so langsam
habe ich den eindruck sie sind in der
oppositionsrolle auch wirklich
angekommen anders kann ich mehrere
debattenbeiträge nicht erklären der
kollege post hat es hier schon erläutert
und ich will es hier noch mal verstärken
in sonntagsreden predigen sie die
schwarze null hier machen sie am
fließband neue ausgaben vorschläge ich
habe schon am anfang dieser woche gesagt
die grundrechenarten reichen um zu
wissen dass das nicht zusammenpasst mit
einer verantwortungsvollen
haushaltspolitik in dieser schwierigen
zeit wo wir gemeinsam in der
verantwortung stehen hat das überhaupt
nichts zu tun liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der uni
gleichzeitig war schon auffällig dass
für die unionsabgeordneten die atomkraft
dann auf einmal auch im einzelplan elf
steckte oder an anderen einzelplänen
immer wieder haben sie die atomkraft
hier beschönigt und beschworen in dieser
woche und damit einmal mehr bewiesen
dass sie unfähig sind aus der
vergangenheit zu lernen aus ihren
eigenen fehlern der vergangenheit zu
lernen aber ich möchte sie erinnern sie
haben in ihrer energiepolitik historisch
versagt sie haben uns abhängig gemacht
von putins russischen gas sie haben
gegen jede windkraftanlage gekämpft sie
haben bis zum schluss nutzten zwei
verteidigt obwohl wir sie immer wieder
davor gewarnt haben vor den
energiepolitischen konsequenzen vor den
geopolitischen konsequenzen vor der
abriss barkeit nun wollen wir sie erneut
die kernkraft wird die preise nicht
senken sie ist ein unkalkulierbares
risiko sie trägt nicht zur
netzstabilität bei und sie ist eine
unbezahlbare hypothek für künftige
generation liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ihre altlasten lieber union
ihre altlasten sind mit verantwortlich
für die preissteigerungen mit denen wie
es jetzt zu tun haben während sie in
ihrer fraktion pro atom negativer
entwickelt haben hat robert habeck die
gasspeicher gefüllt die sie uns leer
hinterlassen haben sie tragen
verantwortung fangen sie endlich damit
an ihre energiepolitik an der
wirklichkeit zu orientieren und nicht an
kinder ideologie
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
wissen um die zumutungen in dieser zeit
deswegen haben wir eine entlastungs
paket geschnürt das die ganze breite der
bevölkerung abdeckt die maßnahmen des
dritten entlastungs paketes greifen zum
teil auch schon kurzfristig
beispielsweise die energiepreis
pauschale oder der heizkostenzuschuss
zwei beides noch in diesem jahr andere
maßnahmen wie das höhere bürgergeld die
wohngeldreform oder auch die kindergeld
steigerung greifen dann im neuen jahr
insgesamt haben wir die menschen in
unserem land in der krise dann um
beinahe 100 milliarden euro entlastet
und das zeigt uns doch klar und deutlich
die ampel koalition nimmt ihre
verantwortung hier war in dieser krisen
beachteten und wir grüne werden dabei
weiterhin natürlich darauf achten dass
besonders die menschen entlastet werden
die es dringend nötig haben das sind die
menschen mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen niemand darf unverschuldet auf
der strecke bleiben in dieser zeit und
das ist für uns die handlungsmaxime und
deswegen bin ich dem finanzminister
christian lindner auch sehr dankbar dass
er jüngst in der süddeutschen
klargestellt hat dass er unter
bestimmten umständen das aussetzen der
schuldenbremse tatsächlich dann auch
nicht ausschließt dass es für ihn kein
dogma ist und das ist natürlich richtig
denn es ist zutiefst pragmatisch die
schuldenbremse ist kein selbstzweck und
wir werden uns aus der krise nicht
heraussparen können dafür braucht es
eine aktive haushaltspolitik gerade vor
dem hintergrund letzte sieber tendenzen
und dafür sind wir bereit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der blick auf
den haushalt der
blick auf den haushalt zeigt wir müssen
auch grundsätzlich über
finanzierungsfragen sprechen die
abschöpfung von zusatzgewinnen ist
aktuell ein richtiger und notwendiger
schritt für den wir grüne uns auch sehr
stark eingesetzt haben wir sollten
darüber hinaus aber schon auch
konstruktiv über die frage debattieren
wie wir haushalt schon die räume
erweitern können und da möchte ich auf
die summe der 65 milliarden euro für das
entlastungspaket zurückkommen 65
milliarden euro ist nämlich auch die
größenordnung und ich verweist er auf
einen bericht des umweltbundesamtes aus
dem jahr 2021 es ist die größenordnung
auf die das finanzministerium jedes jahr
verzichtet für fossile subventionen das
ist eine gewaltige summe geld und ich
sage auch ganz klar und muss
unmissverständlich wir können diese
subvention in dieser phase natürlich
nicht von jetzt auf gleich gleich
abschaffen das wäre preistreibend und
fatal in dieser situation was wir aber
brauchen und das will ich hier schon
diesen impuls will ich schon auch setzen
das ist ein fahrplan für den sukzessiven
abbau von klimaschädlichen subvention
das ist nicht nur der einzig logische
schritt im sinne des klimaschutzes
sondern eben auch um für neue
finanzierungsspielräume zu sorgen für
gute soziale und klimapolitik führende
vorhaben dieser regierung lieber herr
präsident ein letzter satz neue willst
auch die haushaltsberatungen wir haben
spielräume wir werden sie nutzen
herzlichen dank so weit will und meine
damen und herren sie sehen ist wir
erwarten auf ein statement von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz zum tod von
queen elizabeth 2 er hat schon gestern
auf twitter her
gedankt für ihren einsatz und auch
geschrieben sie wird fehlen nicht
zuletzt ihr wohl noch voller humor bis
dieses statement kompletten wir aber
natürlich in den beratungen zum haushalt
20 23
energiepreise sind allein im august um
35 prozent gestiegen die lebensmittel
werden teurer das neue euro ticket ist
ersatzlos ausgelaufen für viele menschen
spitzt sich die lage immer weiter zu für
die 14 millionen menschen die in armut
leben die zu niedriglöhnen arbeiten oder
auf die grundsicherung angewiesen sind
und zunehmend auch für normal
verdienende und nun hat die
bundesregierung nach langem hin und her
ein drittes entlastungs paket
beschlossen indem sie ja zumindest mal
korrigiert haben das rennen darin und
rentner und studierende bei der energie
pauschale erst mal leer ausgingen was im
übrigen eine ungerechtigkeit
sondergleichen war eine einmalzahlung
ist sicher besser als nächster sieg
verbucht viele menschen werden damit
nicht über den winter kommen und
deswegen brauchen wir für kleinere und
mittlere einkommen ein monatliches
inflations geld das es nötig und nicht
die weitere steuerliche entlastung für
besserverdienende und
sind als den kreis der
wohngeldberechtigten auszuweiten wäre
ein bundesweiter mieten deckel ball dann
könnte man mietsteigerung verhindern
statt sie auf kosten der allgemeinheit
auszugleichen meine damen und herren
eine wirklich sinnvolle maßnahme da
würden würden sie auf einen schlag
millionen von mieterinnen und mietern
entlasten unterstrich ist ihr
entlastungspaket enttäuschend es ist
sozial unausgewogen es ist nicht
nachhaltig und das kritisieren ja auch
sozialverbände und gewerkschaften
menschen die auf grundsicherung
angewiesen sind bekommen in diesem jahr
überhaupt keinen cent mehr gar keine
hilfe mehr er hat mir regelwerk soll
erst ab januar steigen um 50 euro
notwendig wären mindestens 200 euro pro
monat damit die menschen in armut leben
viele menschen wird auch die tafeln
angewiesen mit fünf euro 19 pro tag für
lebensmittel ja davon kann man doch
nicht leben meine damen und herren und
diese menschen empfinden spar tipps wie
die benutzung von waschlappen zu recht
als absolut zynisch und das ist es auch
vor allem solange man mit 200
stundenkilometern über deutsche
autobahnen fahren kann weil die fdp ein
tempolimit für teufelszeug hält dann
sparen wir uns bitte solche absurden
spart sich die menschen bleiben
die wichtigste frage nämlich die
explodierenden gaspreise die genommen
sie einfach aus keinen preis deckel kein
kostengünstiges grund konnte ihren
keiner maßnahmen gegen die spekulation
stattdessen führt die ampel eine
gasanlage 1 die ausgerechnet für
erweiterte dann die verbraucher am
verbraucher zahlen sollen die mit gas
heizen worauf ihre normale miete
überhaupt keinen einfluss hat wir sagen
die gas umlage muss weg wir brauchen ein
verbot von strom und gas stellen niemand
im dunklen sich oder frieren muss weil
er oder sie die rechnung nicht bezahlen
kann und an der gasanlage haben ja
offensichtlich die konzerne fleißig
mitgeschrieben und dabei rauskam dass
nicht nur notleidende konzerne sie
bekommen sollen sondern auch unternehmen
die richtig gut verdienen die sich
gerade dumm und dusselig verging in
dieser krise weil es ist ja nicht so
dass alle ärmer werden kann allein die
mineralölkonzerne haben im letzten
quartal einen über gewinn von 38
milliarden gemacht und auch konzerne wie
rwe verdienen gerade gut andere länder
schöpfen diese über gewinne ab spanien
zum beispiel gerade über gewinn steuer
eingeführt für energie konzerne und
banken und damit finanzieren den
kostenfreien pnv dass meine damen und
herren ist sozial gerecht und dass das
klimafreundliche nicht da hat die
deutsche bundesregierung nun ist sie
allgemein bekannt dass die fdp die
schutzpatrone der konzerne ist aber
liebe spd und liebe grüne sie können
sich nicht bei jeder frage und bei jeder
sinnvolle reform hinter christian
lindner verstecken und die fdp als grund
anführen warum das alles nicht möglich
ist die spd stellt den kanzler und nicht
die fdp und wenn sie die über gewinn
steuer für sinnvoll halten dann führen
sie sie bitte 1
aber eine art die über geringe steuer
die nämlich die bereits angelaufen jetzt
aufgelaufen über gewinne abschöpft
trauen sie sich nicht dran da konnte bis
zu 100 milliarden euro einbringen das
wir brauchen um die menschen zu
entlasten und auch um das neue euro
ticket zu verlängern und er kannst da
sagt er selbst dass das neue euro ticket
eine der besten ideen gewesen sei die
die ampel je gehabt hat da sage ich
ihnen standen sie doch bitte ihre
schlechten ideen ein wie die gas umlage
um nicht die wenigen guten meine damen
und herren wir
wollen die schuldenbremse einhalten und
verhindern gleichzeitig eine sozial
gerechte steuerpolitik damit verhindern
sie investitionen und das ist
unverantwortlich
meine damen und herren die gaskrise ist
auch eine folge einer verfehlten
energiepolitik der letzten jahre
sehenden auges hat man sich abhängig
gemacht von fossilen energien und damit
auch von russischen importen stadt die
energiewende voranzubringen und das
kritisieren wir wir brauchen an die
energiewende und nicht das festhalten an
fossilen energie
verbrennt nicht endlich komme zum
schluss letzte satz wir brauchen druck
in diesem land in großbritannien haben
gewerkschaften und aktive gesagt und
nach wissen genug ist genug und streiten
und kämpfen mit protesten für entlastung
für soziale gerechtigkeit druck ist auch
in diesem land notwendig soziale
prozesse damit sich was zum gut lebt
meine damen und herren
der tod der britischen königin
elizabeth der zweite bewegt und berührt
uns alle
weltweit ist trauer und grosser
anteilnahme zu spüren die kerzen und
blumen vor dem buckingham palace in
landen aber auch vor der britischen
botschaft in berlin belegen welchem
platz elisabeth die zweite im herzen so
vieler bürgerinnen und bürger innehatte
auch hier in deutschland
großbritannien hat seine königin
verloren die welt eine jahrhundertfigur
ihre regentschaft erstreckte sich über
mehr als 70 jahre eine halbe ewigkeit
die queen
verkörperte das beste unseres
gemeinsamen europäischen erbes
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit
ihr leben hat elizabeth zweiter ganz dem
dienst in ihrem land und ihrem volk
gewidmet ihr pflichtbewusstsein war eben
so unerschütterlich legendär
deutschland blickt voller dankbarkeit
auf die queen die neben vielen anderen
auch dafür stand dass sich die einstigen
kriegsgegner großbritannien und
deutschland wieder aus süden konnten
ihre zahlreichen besucher hier bei uns
waren auch wegen ihrer besonderen
präsenz und zugewandtheit herausragende
ereignisse die bei vielen noch in
erinnerung sind
meine damen und herren ich habe der
britischen premierministerin des tras
unsere anteilnahme übermittelt auch
deutschland trauert um die britische
königin queen elizabeth ii wir wünschen
ihrem nachfolger schals dem dritten
kraft geschick und das nötige glück für
sein neues amt
vielen dank
sich etwa der betrag die sie in der
vorgängerregierung noch für ganz andere
dinge eingeplant hatten also das zeigt
schon dass hier unter vielen das war
hier noch einmal die worte von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz zum tod von
queen elizabeth der zweite noch einmal
mit besonderer würdigung auch was die
vierte deutsch-britische versöhnung
erreicht hat in ihrer
amtszeit
und damit gehen wir nun einmal das haben
diese tage in sich mit einem harten
schnitt wieder zurück in die
haushaltsberatungen dort spricht gerade
der parlamentarische staatssekretär im
bundesfinanzministerium
florian toncar
beschäftigen müssen kann man eigentlich
das gleiche geld bessere ergebnisse
bekommen das ist doch die entscheidende
lehre aus der zeitenwende aus den neuen
rahmenbedingungen im haushalt die wir
haben und genau der verweigern sie sich
systematisch liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union denn
ich habe diese woche bei 35 stunden
beratungszeit zum haushalt etwa 30
stunden hier auf diesem platz verbracht
und sehr aufmerksam zugehört und ich
kann nur eines berichten das wissen sie
wahrscheinlich nicht alle hier die union
fordert in jedem einzelnen einzelplan
mehrausgaben innen außen verteidigung
verkehr soziales wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung in jedem
einzelplan mehr geld aber kein einziger
finanzierungsvorschlag jeder weiß dass
das nicht geht was ihr hier vortragen
sie tun es trotzdem und das ist in hohem
maße unredlich liebe kolleginnen wegen
ich denke übrigens dass gerade das was
sie hier diese woche auch gezeigt haben
ich muss wirklich sagen zu ihrer
verteidigung es gab einen
einsparvorschlag heute morgen der
kollege tom mit einen
staatssekretärsposten im
innenministerium streichen der zurzeit
gar nicht besetzt ist also kategorie
albernheiten und im grunde das in der
tat was muss ich ihnen zugestehen aber
in wahrheit ist doch das was wir diese
woche gerade von ihnen erlebt haben als
die seriöse demokratische opposition
hier in diesem haus ist doch eigentlich
das beste zeugnis dafür dass dieser
haushalt grundlegend in die richtige
richtung geht es gibt keine grundlegende
anderen vorschläge wie man das geld in
diesem land anders ausgeben könnte außer
mehr für alles und das ist sicherlich
nicht genug liebe kolleginnen zu nehmen
und da muss man ja passt da muss man ja
fast die linksparteien noch in schutz
nehmen die wollen nämlich auch mehr
thale aber die sagen wenigstens dass sie
dafür mehr schulden machen oder mehr
steuern erheben wollen das halte ich für
falsch aber ehrlicher ehrliche ist das
allemal ist dass er sich von ihnen diese
woche gehören haben und
wir stellen uns jetzt in der zeitenwende
unsere verantwortung wir treffen
entscheidungen beispielsweise der
koalitionsausschuss am letzten sonntag
weitere entscheidungen wir haben
folgende energie minister ist heute ja
in europa mit wichtigen themen befasst
im kreis seiner kollegen wir
kommunizieren offen wir sagen auch
selbstverständlich gibt es hier nicht
die einfache lösung wer einfache
lösungen in dieser krise propagiert der
hat nicht die lösung eines problems in
sind er hat ein ganz anderes spiel im
kopf und davor kann ich im sinne der
demokratie nur warnen freue mich auf die
auf beratung
vielen dank herr kollege konnte
nächste fällige allerdings reiner cdu
csu fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren diese
woche wurde der haushalt 20 23
angebracht weil ich keine einfache
aufgabe in einer schwierigen zeit aber
meine damen und herren ich vermisse
ideen und innovationen für die zukunft
unseres landes und dabei haben sie auch
vergessen dass einen starken staat
einige ein tier regierung ausmacht und
ihre kolleginnen kollegen der appell von
einigkeit habe ich in den letzten tagen
und wochen bei ihnen wenig gespürt ein
thema
zum entlastungspaket herr kollege komme
ich gleich noch ein thema die
entscheidung zur atomkraft verlängerung
ist in meinen augen ein witz oder dem
biogas deckel nicht aufzuheben ist das
gleiche wenn aus zum teil ideologischen
gründen nicht gehandelt wird dann kann
man sagen sie bringen unser land nicht
voran
und wenn sie jetzt wieder mit
altbewährten leider kommen wir waren ja
16 jahre in der regierungsverantwortung
ja das stimmt 16 gute jahre für
deutschland denn vor diesem 16 jahren
waren wir das schlusslicht in europa und
in diesen 16 jahren kamen wir zur
lokomotive europas
und das und das mit einem ausgeglichenen
haushalts mit einer schwarzen null und
dem regelmäßigen ausgleich zb der kalten
progression und auch haben wir schon in
der opposition viele vorschläge gemacht
die sie leider gottes immer wieder
abgelehnt haben und eines muss man auch
dazu sagen in den 16 jahren waren zwölf
jahre die spd nutzt dabei mit führenden
häusern und vier jahre auch die fdp das
wollen wir nicht vergessen
meine damen und herren am wochenende
wurde sie
verzeihen wir den ausdruck ausbesserung
entlastungs paket mit vielen
ankündigungen vorgelegt es sind ja
einige gute vorschläge dabei los wenn
ich wenn ich eines höher dass es ein
volumen von 65 milliarden hat da muss
man der ehrlichkeit weil wir auch sagen
den bund betreffen gut 30 milliarden sie
müssen das noch mit den ländern und zum
teil mit den kommunen verhandeln das
hätten sie schon längst machen müssen
das haben sie versäumt das haben sie
versorgt sie machen den bürgern in
unserem land was vor mit den
entlastungen
ich bin mal gespannt was da rauskommt
ein beispiel das neun euro ticket in
drei monaten haben sie es nicht
geschafft mit den ländern ein
nachfolgeprogramm auszuhandeln dann zu
den kosten drei monate ca 2,5 milliarden
über das neue euro tickets streiten oder
nicht neu geplant 1,5 milliarden euro
aus bundes seite und dann wollen sie
vielleicht noch die gleiche summe
ausländer seite noch mehr 1,5 milliarden
sind wir bei drei milliarden ja wenn es
dann noch eine weitere drei monate oder
dreieinhalb monate eine entlastung
bringe oder wie sollte es dann am ende
der tage laufen und ich sage ihnen eines
die menschen im ländlichen raum die die
möglichkeit nicht haben wie in den
städtischen gebieten den öpnv so zu
nutzen wenn du um fünf uhr morgens als
krankenschwester im krankenhaus arbeiten
muss denen sind sie egal oder sie sind
ihnen egal so geht es nicht meine damen
und herren sie vernachlässigen in diesem
entlastungspaket voll und ganz den
ländlichen raum
würde mich schämen an ihrer seite
unsere vorschläge liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe kollegin lagen lagen auf
den tisch und jetzt kam jetzt höre ich
gerade vorhin dass die mittelschicht bzw
der mittelstand entlastet wird jetzt
habe ich ihn mir eines klar kann man dem
vorschlag des bundeswirtschaftsministers
folgen und produktion aufhören in den
winterschlaf gehen als bäcker und
metzger ob dies der richtige weg ist die
sei dahin gestellt aber es wird so nicht
gehen wir müssen die mittelschicht
genauso entlasten und die hart
arbeitende mittelschicht genauso
entlasten vor dem ließ sich in ihrem
programm relativ wenig bis gar nichts
und der mittelstand der mittelstand die
tragende säule unserer wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung ist in diesem programm
0,0 erwähnt glaube ich nicht gespannt
was am ende der tage com ende
und ich gebe dem staatssekretär recht
wenn er das thema inflation anspricht ja
es ist eines unserer größten unserer
größten probleme die geldentwertung in
unserem land aber meine damen und herren
was machen wir dagegen was läuft dagegen
an ankündigung dass man das mary tor das
system ändern wollen das wissen wir doch
schon lange oder sie müssten es
eigentlich schon lange wissen dass der
strompreis durch die decke geht es
hätten wir schon lange machen müssen und
das hauptthema der überbordenden
inflation sind einfach mal die
energiepreise wenn man dann die
lebensmittelpreise noch mit dazu nehmen
an jedem lebensmittel hängt ein stück
weit auch energie trat sie hätten das
schon längst an tragen müssen sie haben
es nicht getan sie haben das versäumen
ich hoffe sie hören in den
haushaltsberatungen
auf die vorschläge der union die
vorschläge werden gut sein ich habe
größtes vertrauen in die haushalte ich
war dass selbst einige jahre mit dabei
wünsche alles gute für die verhandlungen
für die verhandlungen tun sie es nicht
um ihre ideologie zu befriedigen tun sie
es für die menschen in unserem land
danke schön und ganz sagte
minister rednerin es bettina hagedorn
die stellvertretender vorsitzender des
haushaltsausschusses und mitglied der
spd fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen liebe
zuschauer
ich bin
seit 21 jahren im haushaltsausschuss und
ich dachte ich habe schon viele krisen
erlebt mit der finanz und
wirtschaftskrise vor allen dingen 2008
2009 und mit den flüchtlingen corona und
es gab zeiten da habe ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen können dass es noch ärger
kommen könnte aber wir erleben genau das
jetzt weil die multiplen krisen stellen
diese regierung haben diese regierung
als sie noch nicht einmal 100 jahre 100
tage im amt war vor immense
herausforderung gestellt die sie
hervorragend gemeistert haben und ich
weiß nicht lieber alois rainer du warst
nicht so viel im plenum diese woche wie
ich weiß nicht wo du gehört haben wird
streit zwischen der koalition
also ich war genau wie der herr
staatssekretär tonga über 20 stunden ihr
habt den debatten gelauscht und ich muss
sagen das war ein fairer dass man gute
beratung und außerdem bitte wenden sie
nicht den eindruck wir würden hier einen
fertigen haushalt beraten wir fangen
erst mit den beratungen
und meine vorräte haben schon darauf
hingewiesen dass die teilweise auf
seiten der größten oppositionspartei der
cdu/csu leider wieder eine relativ akten
freie debatte erleben mussten und damit
werden sie allerdings dieses mal ganz
bestimmt ihrer verantwortung als größte
oppositionspartei in dieser krise nicht
gerecht wir brauchen eine starke aber
auch eine seriöse und eine anzunehmende
opposition die letzten
haushaltsberatungen waren schon na ja im
haushaltsausschuss mit der union bahnt
sich in relativer ausfallen ich hoffe
dass es dieses mal besser wird und ich
hoffe dass die ankündigung von alois
rainer dass sie spannende vorschläge
einbringen werden auch der wahrheit
entspricht wenn ich mir aber diese
debatte an höre diese woche dann gab es
ja ein thema das jetzt nicht so ganz
viel mit dem haushalt zu tun hat das
haben sie ja richtig geritten das war
nämlich das thema atomkraft und
ich freue mich dass mein kollege bruno
höhle schon soviel dazu gesagt hat was
ich alles unterschreiben könnte aber ich
will noch ein faktum hinzuführen denn
der ausstieg aus der atomkraft von
rot-grün 20 jahre ungefähr her das war
ein vertrag und die energiekonzerne
haben ihn unterschrieben und weil sie
das getan haben und rot grün das so klug
verhandelt hat wäre es nicht möglich
gewesen regress auf kosten der
steuerzahler zu fahren und dann dann kam
die cdu fdp regierung und hat im oktober
2010 die verlängerung der laufzeiten
beschlossen und damit die verträge
aufgehoben und nur fünf monate später
kamen fukushima und hals über kopf haben
sie auf einmal das was sie fünf monate
vorher beschlossen haben wieder
rückgängig gemacht und wissen sie war
wozu das geführt hat das wissen sie
natürlich aber ich will es noch mal der
öffentlichkeit sagen dass dadurch die
stromkonzerne die atomkraftbetreiber
dass sie dadurch kresken spruch hat nun
den haben sie eingeklagt und zwar mit
erfolg vom bundesverfassung gericht 2016
und wer muss die suppe auslöffeln
in der letzten koalition in der letzten
unserer gemeinsamen koalition ein
finanzminister olaf scholz musste aus
steuermitteln 2,4 milliarden euro
bezahlen an regressen stromkonzerne
vattenfall hat 1,4 erhalten rwe 880
millionen baby 80 millionen und e on
preussenelektra 42,5 millionen das war
das ergebnis ihrer völlig
unverantwortliche politik und auch vor
diesem hintergrund müssen wir da keine
ratschläge von ihnen waren
und wir haben
ganz besonders sie haben ja in allen
bereichen mehr ausgaben gefordert aber
ich will mir mal zwei bereiche
herauspicken das eine ist die bundeswehr
und da tut es ihnen ja vielleicht weh
hoffe ich jedenfalls wenn ich ihre
erinnerungen etwas auffrischen dass es
auch eine cdu geführte fdp cdu fdp
geführte regierung war die sagen und
schreibe bei der bundeswehr 8 milliarden
euro gekürzt hat 8 milliarden euro
dieses erbe haben wir dann mit unserer
zweiten großen koalition geerbt und wir
haben alleine in den ersten vier jahren
von 213 bis 217 dann gemeinsam die
bundeswehr von 320 bundeswehr von knapp
33 auf 37 milliarden euro gestärkt also
um vier milliarden euro in vier jahren
und dann kam die nächste kroko und es
waren gute zeiten ist ein konjunkturell
guten zeiten und wir haben in dieser
zeit man finanzminister olaf scholz von
2 bis 2019 noch einmal sechs milliarden
euro oben drauf gepackt und wir stehen
jetzt dann kam ja die beiden
konjunkturpakete jahre da wurde es noch
mal gestärkt und wir sind jetzt bei
dauerhaften über 50 milliarden euro für
den verteidigungsetat davon hätten sie
nicht einmal geträumt und dann immer
noch das 100 milliarden euro sondern
also das was diese ampel regierung in
diesem bereich zugunsten auch zum zur
sicherheit auch der soldatinnen und
soldaten angemessen für die aufgaben für
diverse warten müssen geleistet hat das
haben wir mit ihm so nicht hingekriegt
und dann will ich noch sagen die zahlen
habe ich hier schon vor zwei tagen
vorgetragen dass das gleiche für das
ministerium für
entwicklungszusammenarbeit gilt das
nämlich ist in der in ihrer
regierungszeit in der cdu fdp regierung
seit konstant bei 6 milliarden geblieben
sogar noch gekürzt worden und wir haben
es schrittweise in der großen koalition
auf initiative der spd und nicht auf die
initiative des damaligen gerd müller wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass der etat mehr
als verdoppelt worden ist und darauf
sind wir stolz und darum
wie diese regierung
verantwortungsbewusst auch in
außenpolitischen fragen und haushalten
in diese schwierige zeit und alle haben
gesagt sie freuen sich auch die beratung
die wir noch nicht ganz sicher ob ich
mich freuen soll aber wir werden sie
meistern
bettina hagedorn dass ich die
spd-fraktion nächste redner macht sich
schon bereit kein gottschalk der
finanzpolitische sprecher der afg fremd
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrter herr präsident verehrte
damen und herren hier im hause liebe
zuschauer
dieser vertrag in ihrer koalition hieß
mehr fortschritt wagen ich empfehle
ihnen den abtritt zu wagen dass wir für
deutschland gut und was ich jetzt sage
in richtung union hätte ich niemals
gedacht weniger fortschritt nein mehr
rückschritt in allen gesellschaftlichen
finanziellen und wirtschaftlichen
bereichen hatten wir nicht mal unter der
merkel cdu meine damen und herren und
die krise und inzwischen deutschland
wirtschaftsinstituten da adressiert kam
an den finanzminister und den
wirtschaftsminister der jetzt nicht da
ist aber sein staatssekretärs angekommen
die wirtschaftsinstitute prognostizieren
eine rezession die deutschland 150
milliarden euro kosten wird so schreibt
dass das handelsblatt gerade sie wollen
also ernsthaft an der schwarzen null
festhalten und im nächsten jahr an einem
ausgeglichenen haushalt wir werden sie
da an ihren worten messen aber das wird
ein langer traum bleiben meine damen und
herren die politik der letzten
jahrzehnte schlägt nun voll ins kontor
alles was unsere partei die afb wovor
sie gewarnt hat eine verfehlte
energiepolitik eine verfehlte
migrationspolitik eine verfehlte
außenpolitik und eine verfehlte steuer
und wirtschaftspolitik schlägt nun voll
zu buche zur ezb will ich gar nichts
sagen meine damen und herren strom und
das ist im supermarkt und über alles so
teuer geworden durch das gas das wir mit
einer weile diese krise bis tief in den
mittelstand spüren mittelstands
entlastungen fehlanzeige
unternehmenssteuerreform fehlanzeige da
kam auch nichts von ihnen meine damen
und herren von der union und diese 300
euro meine damen und herren die sie dann
auch noch versteuern dürfen die sie
einmalig bekommen die sind für mich ein
almosen und ein ruhen aber keine hilfe
meine damen und herren
und zum umgang mit unseren meinungen da
vielleicht mal an frau fieser adressiert
und die anderen damen und herren die
hier im haus also andere projekte
propagieren ich kann mich noch sehr gut
an die bundestagswahl erinnern da gab es
ein plakat grün am ist mieterhöhung
spritpreis krise strompreis explosion
diese wahrheit sicherlich noch mal auf
die sprünge helfen diese schöne plakat
das wurde natürlich von ihnen unter und
linien hause als hetze bezeichnung es
ist blanke realität zeigt aber wie sieht
mit andersdenkenden und vor allen dingen
mit der wissenschaft inzwischen umgehen
meine damen und herren
alles böse hetzer ich weiß meine damen
und herren eine wuchtige entlastung soll
das sein da rausgekommen meine damen und
herren laues lüftchen 95 milliarden in
drei entlastungspaket meine damen und
herren die bild -zeitung sie hat den weg
zur tugend zurück gefunden sie hat ja
auch den greta jüngeren und anderen
dingen dem atomausstieg gefüllt übrigens
vielen dank für die krisenbewältigung
vor hagedorn meine damen und herren die
bild sagte der fleißige ist der dumme
und niemals hat ein wort mehr das rennen
das auf ihre politik gelegt meine damen
und herren
kein geld der welt wird das abfedern was
sie anrichten und diese regierungsbank
ist inzwischen die größte bank der welt
geworden meine damen und herren das ist
mal fakt herr scholz wir handeln als
bundeskanzler ist audi hier bis
bestenfalls genau so lückenhaft und
schlecht wie ihre erinnerungen fall
warburg und comics als lehrer würde man
sagen glatte sechs hinsetzen versetzung
gefährdet während in russland die öl und
gas verkäufe mehr als die kriegskosten
einbringen das von 2,5 billionen rubel
bilanziert das sind etwa 41,3 milliarden
euro meine damen und herren halten wir
an diesem unsinnigen sanktionen
festigung unserer wirtschaft den
menschen und unsere demokratie schaden
meine damen und herren das beste
entlastungspaket ist der stopp dieser
unsinnigen sie sanktionen und das ist
auch ihre schuld der bad bank bei der
damen und herren kommen aber auch noch
mal zu er in lind nach denn sie tragen
die hauptverantwortung dass sie sich
hier als mittäter und helfer sozusagen
beteiligen das ist schon skandalös der
bundesrechnungshof sagt völlig zu recht
die ware belastung sind nicht mehr
schulden von 17,2 sondern 78 milliarden
euro sie verschleiern sie trägt sie
meine damen und herren insoweit kann man
unseren finanzminister mittlerweile als
den größten trickbetrüger der
bundesrepublik bezeichnet er ist besser
als gar massa legt er hat es nur auf 20
milliarden gebracht meine damen und
herren
spannend wird also insoweit sein wo sie
sprudelnde steuereinnahmen in den
nächsten jahren bei diesen insolvenzen
haben ist noch nicht da der herberge ich
hätte gern ein bisschen nachhilfe
gegeben an dieser stelle bei dieser
insolvenzwelle werden sie keine spur den
steuereinnahmen ernten meine damen und
herren hören sie also auf mit der grünen
transformation ist ein rohrkrepierer und
das comeback ist nicht kann kleine
empfehlung an die jüngeren zuschauer
gehen sie mal bei youtube in das format
jung und naiv hier könnte man sagen alt
und naiv dass stammelt dieser
bundeswirtschaftsminister völlig wäre es
zeugs wie zu base drei keine ahnung war
wusste er genau die bafin prüft
handwerkerrechnungen herzlichen
glückwunsch da ist diese insolvenz
entgleisung ja noch harmlos gegen meine
damen und herren also insoweit ist der
beste beste schritt für unser land
machen sie den platz frei für eine
vernünftige regierung und treten sie
zurück
die übersetzung da acht sekunden sofort
ansonsten die bürger der auf die straße
geht und gegen diese unsinnige politik
demonstriert das ist ihr recht und sie
sind deshalb keine rechten weil sie ihr
recht in kauf nehmen meine damen und
herren wir freuen uns auf die beratung
der kollege kommen sie jetzt zum
schlussbericht bin dabei ist vorbei
heute
bei uns sind sie immer sehr genau also
wenn ich mit 28 sekunden darüber sehr
genau gehen denn es ist etwas was sie
vielleicht noch lernen sollte
ich will nur darauf hinweisen dass ich
das zumindest für und parlamentarisch
alter ein mitglied der bundesregierung
zum trikot zieren denn nicht legt
nochmal über nachrichten eine
ordnungsmaßnahme vor
bündnis 90/die grünen
er präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
herein es ist ja in jeder beziehung gut
wenn man auch mal fragen stellt aber sie
haben ja nur fragen gestellt und keine
einzige antwort gegeben und das von der
opposition die so lange regiert und frau
christa sie haben gesagt sie erwarten
dass diese regierung gesetzespaket
gesetzentwürfe vorliegt das wenig ihre
aufgabe ich will sie mal daran erinnern
es gab hier 16 jahren opposition die hat
sogar gesetzentwürfe vorgelegt man kann
nicht nur unterschiedlich gut regieren
man kann doch umfliegen opponieren
offensichtlich
meine damen und herren frau wissler
sie haben ein paar punkte angesprochen
was die sozialen fragen dieser zeit
angeht auf die ich gleich noch mal
genauer eingehen werde aber sie haben
ganz spannender weise ein paar punkten
ihre rede ausgelassen beispielsweise
warum sie ihr sagen man müsste doch viel
schneller aus den fossilen energien aus
den fossilen abhängigkeiten aussteigen
und ihre fraktion sich gestern
entschieden hat sahra wagenknecht den
einstieg in neue fossile abhängigkeiten
faktisch zu fordern durch das ende der
sanktionen und damit auch durch die
inbetriebnahme von nord stream 2 was
wollen sie denn jetzt fossile
abhängigkeiten überwinden oder fossile
abhängigkeiten forcieren und uns noch
weiter von kriegsverbrechern berlino
putin treiben lassen das ist die frage
die sie beantworten müssen und ich hatte
gestern ja an dieser stelle hat an
dieser stelle ja dass ein wortwechsel
bis verwarnt pflicht und herrn ernst
seitdem häufen sich bei mir in den
sozialen medien die hass kommentare die
bedrohungen wenn mal jemand wenn ich mal
wieder in nordrhein-westfalen bin mit
dem fahrrad könnte es zu einem unfall
kommen und jetzt sagen sie vermutlich
das wäre unfair und es wäre unredlich
sie in verbindung mit diesen dingen zu
setzen nur weil das zufälligerweise
passiert nachdem sarah wagenknecht und
miteinander gesprochen haben dann möchte
ich sie fragen wie kann es sein dass
ihre fraktionskollegin sevim dagdelen
vor der parteizentrale der grünen
demonstriert und sagt die eigentlichen
aggressoren in dieser zeit seien
annalena baerbock und robert habeck
diese wirklich ihr licht handel
beschämende relativierung der
kriegsverbrechen russlands die können
sie doch nicht hinnehmen wenn sie das
leid der menschen wenn sie die sorgen
die berechtigten sorgen der menschen
davor ob sie sich die stromrechnung noch
leisten können instrumentalisieren für
diese außenpolitische ihr fahrt dann
haben sie auch ihre verantwortung nicht
ernst genommen
meine damen und herren ich
mache mir sehr große sorgen
ich mache mir sehr viele gedanken über
die sozialen fragen dieser zeit ich weiß
nicht keiner kann das heute wissen ob
das entlastungspaket 123 ausreichen wird
um alle probleme die menschen haben zu
bewältigen ich kann ihnen sagen diese
bundesregierung wird nicht aufhören sich
über diese fragen gedanken zu machen und
wenn es notwendig ist daraus auch die
konsequenzen zu ergreifen wenn dieses
dritte entlastungspaket nicht die
letzten fragen beantwortet dann wird es
auch nicht die letzte entlastung dieser
bundesregierung gewesen sein
und in dieser aktuellen situation in der
die inflation die eine unbestreitbare
tatsache und auch eine große gefahr ist
sowohl für menschen mit wenig einkommen
aber am ende für alle und diese
installation natürlich auch ein
volkswirtschaftliches risiko trägt
möchte ich trotzdem die aufmerksamkeit
auf eine andere gefahr lenken wir haben
heute die ankündigung gelesen überall
dass die ezb ihren leitzins erhöht hat
das bedeutet dass wir sozusagen
geldpolitisch rezessions dynamiken
wahrscheinlicher erleben werden und wenn
wir jetzt als haushaltsgesetzgeber uns
fragen was unsere aufgabe dann in dieser
situation ist da müssen wir uns auch die
frage stellen was können wir tun um
rezessions dynamiken ein bisschen
weniger wahrscheinlich zu machen und das
bedeutet dass wir unsere
wirtschaftspolitik unsere fiskalpolitik
diesen veränderten realitäten anpassen
werden und meine damen und herren in
dieser situation
in der ja nicht nur viele menschen mit
dem rücken zur wand stehen sondern viele
unternehmen sich fragen können sie
demnächst noch produzieren sind die
produktionskosten wegen der strom- und
ja deswegen wegen der gaspreis explosion
eigentlich noch ausreichend zu
bewältigen dann ist es doch vollkommen
klar dass eine soziale antwort auf diese
und auch eine ökonomisch kluge antwort
auf dieses multiple krisenszenario mit
inflations und rezessionsgefahren keine
konjunkturpolitik sein muss die am ende
dazu führt das unternehmen noch
produzieren können weil wenn unternehmen
produzieren zahlen sie steuern wenn
unternehmen produzieren gibt es menschen
die in unternehmen arbeiten die zahlen
dann wiederum steuern wenn wir einen
ausgeglichenen
und wenn wir einen stabilen haushalt
auch in der zukunft haben wollen dann
brauchen wir eben auch die
wirtschaftliche basis die auf der
einnahmenseite dafür sorgt dass die
ausgaben die notwendig sind auch
finanziert werden können in diesem sinne
freue ich mich darauf dass wir
konstruktive haushaltsberatungen auch
dieses mal in dieser ampel haben werden
ich bin gespannt ob die opposition
diesmal noch ein bisschen kreativer und
origineller und vielleicht auch ein
bisschen gegenfinanziert wird als beim
letzten mal vielen dank
sagt felix bender von den grünen und
schon auf dem weg zum podium ist otto
fricke fdp haushaltspolitischer sprecher
seiner fraktion aufgerufen werbefirmen
kommt aber sie haben jetzt das wort herr
kollege fricke fdp fraktion ich habe sie
gespürt geschätzter herr präsident dass
sie um eine gebeten haben die wirkung
kollegen schlussrunde ausblick auf die
haushaltsberatungen da ist noch nichts
angefangen deswegen was da von seiten
der cdu zu der frage außer frage kommen
ist eigentlich die selbstentmachtung
wenn man meint dass das parlament nicht
der gesetzgeber sei ich will auf einen
punkt ganz deutlich im haus nämlich ab
rät das thema inflation inflation ist
ein falscher freund des haushaltes wir
glauben jetzt da kommen massenhaft viele
einnahmen wir erkennen aber auch
gleichzeitig als haushälter da kommen
ganz schön viele aufgaben auf uns tun
deswegen die rettungspakete deswegen
vieles andere mehr aber ich will
inflation in das verhältnis auch noch
zum thema schulden stellen wenn wir eine
steigerung der inflation haben wenn wir
die auswirkungen auf die zinsen haben
kommt der falsche freund inflation ganz
schnell angetreten das werden wir in den
nächsten jahren noch erleben deswegen
ist es auch eine aufgabe sparsam zu sein
aber eben nicht geizig und das gehört
zur haushaltspolitik dazu und dann
möchte ich uns alle nochmal ermahnen
dass wir sparsam nicht als geizig
verstehen sondern als vernünftig und
gleichzeitig wenn wir uns die
schuldenbremse angucken auch als etwas
was und da gebe ich dem kollegen man
vergleicht was auch gleichzeitig
rezession bekämpft und deswegen hat
diese schuldenbremse von der alle immer
behaupten sie sehr statisch oder andere
einen schwarzen null fetisch haben
deswegen hat sie eine konjunktur
komponente und ich sage das auch noch
mal für diese koalition da steht nicht
es bleibt bei der neuverschuldung wie
sie im entwurf steht sondern es bleibt
bei der neuverschuldung die uns die
schuldenbremse erlaubt und wenn die
konjunktur noch weiter runter geht wird
das auch auswirkungen auf die schulden
so haben und da bin ich mir sicher dass
wir da noch genau sehen werden wo die
jeweiligen auswirkungen sind denn das
habe ich in diesen debatten bei aller
kritik an der cdu csu in der frage der
gegenvorschläge dann doch erlebt das ist
die menschen wichtig sind dass sie uns
am herzen liegen dass wir spüren welche
ängste da sind das bezweifle ich für
diese vier fraktionen überhaupt nicht an
der stelle das ist das was uns treibt
dass uns das was übrigens allen angst
machen das glaube ich auch für linke und
rechte ich glaube nur dass sie andere
profi pläne damit haben zum schluss
meine damen und herren ich freue mich
auf die weiteren haushaltsberatungen und
weil ich heute wegen queen elizabeth
nicht mit shakespeare will tui es lieber
mit goethe und hat noch einmal eine
bitte an die cdu csu fraktion nimmt doch
einmal eure reden hintereinander gerade
eben in ihnen wieder zwei milliarden wer
der nächste redner der cdu sagt er gibt
aber zu viel geld aus bringt ist in eine
linie sonst ist es wie beim chor von
faust 2 das unzulängliche hier wird's
ereignis herzlichen dank
der kollege florian aus einer cdu csu
fraktion kann darauf ja gleich ein
wunder
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
möchte ich so otto fricke antworten es
ist schon echt mutig es ist schon
wirklich mutig was hier der herr
bundesfinanzminister jetzt in
stellvertretung der staatssekretär
florian tonka heute uns als hausautor
vorlegt mutig deshalb weil man sich
verwundert die augen reibt was hier
alles nicht zusammen passen so ruft die
bundesregierung seit wochen die
bürgerinnen und bürger auf zum verzicht
weniger duschen weniger heizen weniger
auto fahren und und und und was machen
sie im gegenzug
10.000 zusätzliche posten im ministerium
eine ungezügelte verschuldung und eine
desaströse krisenpolitik
es ist ist es daher mehr als sehr
zweifelhaft wie sie liebe ampel
versprochene leitlinien also keine
steuererhöhungen und einhalten der
schuldenbremse am ende einhalten wollen
spätere erinnerungslücken
erinnerungslücken aller herrn
bundeskanzler erlauben wir hier als
haushälter und als unionsfraktion nicht
also mehr wasser predigen und wein
trinken geht wahrlich nicht stoppen sie
diesen wahnsinn
bestes bestes beispiel auf welch
wackeligen fundament der gesamte
haushalt gebaut ist das sogenannte
dritte entlastungspaket ist es überhaupt
nicht in dem haushalt eingepreist 65
milliarden euro eine gigantische summe
soll es kosten keiner weiß jedoch wie
sich diese gigantische summe
zusammensetzt entlastung von
normalverdienern und von
mittelständischen betrieben fehlanzeige
wieder einmal hat die regierung dies
selbst wenigen die handwerker die
freiberufler und die kleinen und
mittleren unternehmen vor allem auch im
ländlichen raum vergessen
jeden tag wird erleichterung von der rot
grünen gelben ampel versprochen die
realität sieht jedoch völlig anders aus
das leben wird von tag zu tag eurer in
unserem land wir steuern auf eine
zweistellige
inflationsrate rechte tasche linke
tasche wäre es besser gewesen wirklich
bedürftigen haushalten zu helfen der
bundeskanzler zitiert in diesem
zusammenhang häufig die liedzeile juli
never walk alone
ich antworte ihnen gerne mit einem
anderen lied let it be lassen sie es
seien die leeren versprechungen und
gehen sie an die wirklichen ursachen an
priorität hat jetzt gegen die horrenden
strompreise vorzugehen und für
netzstabilität zu sorgen da ist der
weitere schnelle ausbau regenerativer
energien und die wasserstoff
infrastruktur
notwendig so wie die dafür notwendigen
netze voll mittelspannungsnetz aber eben
auch die kernenergie das erreicht man
aber nicht indem man zwei von drei
verbleibenden kernkraftwerken den
notbetrieb schick dies ist nicht nur
ökonomisch sondern auch ökologischer
unsinn und verschärft die lage noch
zusätzlich und treibt die strompreise
weiter hoch
also wenn selbst wenn selbst die grünen
aus schweden in der richtung des
bundeswirtschaftsministers habe heute
nachzulesen in allen gazetten
kritisieren dass am ende
solidarität ich zitiere nur dann
funktioniert solange sich niemals selbst
schaden zufügt und hat die kernenergie
politik der grünen in deutschland damit
damit integrität stellt dann sieht man
eines selbst im ausland selbst im
ausland wird von den eigenen
parteikollegen die energiepolitik der
grünen bundesregierung mit roten und
gelben zerlegt die rot grün gelbe
bundesregierung für damit zum eklatanter
inflationstreiber deutschlands
in meiner heimatregion land so thelen
steht eines der letzten kernkraftwerke
mit isar 2 eines der sichersten und
zuverlässigsten kraftwerke der welt und
ich kann ihnen versichern die gesamte
mannschaft vor ort in essenbach steht
bereit um die energieversorgung
deutschlands sicherzustellen
sie braucht jedoch jetzt
planungssicherheit der ball liegt in
ihrem spielfeld liebe ampel lassen sie
ihre ideologischen scheuklappen fallen
und machen das tor wir als union
unterstützen sie da gerne
der der staat ist momentan krasse
inflations gewinn um die bürgerinnen und
bürger wirklich zu helfen fordern wir
als cdu und csu ein dass die steuer
mehreinnahmen des staates auch an die
steuerzahler zurück gegeben werden es
gebietet anstand diejenigen in den fokus
zu nehmen die jeden tag zur arbeit gehen
und unser land am laufen halten zudem
werden in allen branchen mittlerweile
arbeitskräfte gesucht um diese
mehrarbeit überhaupt zu packen müssen
wir beispielsweise freiwillig
überstunden steuerfrei stellen leistung
muss sich wieder lohnen in unserem land
dafür kämpfen werde
und die schuldenbremse ist kein spiel
soll sie steht im grundgesetz nur in
ausnahmesituationen darf sie außer kraft
gesetzt werden und der finanzminister
nimmt sich fürs nächste jahr bereits 40
5 milliarden aus der rücklage
ursprünglich waren geplant 28 milliarden
die langfristige schuldenbremse
einzuhalten wird damit noch schwieriger
so sieht problemlösung aller ampel aus
statt probleme sofort anzugehen
verlagert man diese in die zukunft
und auch der blick auf die
mittelfristige finanzplanung zeigt dass
die koalition weiter in den
schuldenstaat beschreitet im zeitraum 23
bis 26 sind jetzt schon zu sich schulden
von über 56 milliarden euro eingeplant
und leider ist nicht erkennbar dass die
ampel beim sparen an der richtigen
stelle besonderen ehrgeiz herr präsident
ich komme zum schluss die ampel darf am
ende die realität nicht aus den augen
verlieren eine schulden
schuldenexplosion wie es die sich
momentan betreibt ist und wir uns als
union nicht zu machen die ampel ist
deshalb anzuraten schnellstmöglichst
ihren koalitionsvertrag zu überarbeiten
und neu zu priorisieren herzliches
vergelt's gott das zu hören
florian oßner war das hier in der
schlussrunde zum haushaltsgesetz 20 23
445 2 milliarden euro sollen im nächsten
jahr ausgegeben werden das sind 10,2
prozent weniger als im vorjahr und damit
will bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner die schuldenbremse
einhalten das ist unter anderem möglich
weil es weniger ausgaben für die
pandemie gibt und auch mehr
steuereinnahmen so schätzt man
allerdings muss man auch sagen das
entlastungspaket auf das sich die ampel
koalitionäre ja gerade erst geeinigt
haben das ist natürlich in diesem
entwurf noch nicht enthalten und das
heißt er wird es doch noch an dem ein
oder anderen posten noch änderungen
geben auch die werden wir hier natürlich
dann im plenum zur debatte gestellt
sehen denn das hier in dieser woche das
war die erste lesung des haushalts 2023
des gesetzes jetzt den erst einmal
beratungen an im bundesrat wird darüber
diskutiert am 16 september im
haushaltsausschuss bis zum 10 november
stehen die beratungen an und dann sind
wir hier ende november 22 bis 25
november werden dann hier die
abgeordneten die zweite dritte lesung zu
diesem haushaltsgesetz haben und zu
diesem finanzplan wir haben es heute ja
schon mehrmals gehört natürlich schauen
wir auch nach großbritannien
aufgrund des todes von queen elizabeth
ii zweiten ist dort natürlich
viel zu diskutieren einerseits
auch zu gedenken an diese ausnahme frau
die ja schon häufiger gesagt wurde aber
natürlich muss man auch politisch
schauen was bedeutet das für
großbritannien und deswegen verlassen
wir an dieser stelle den bundestag und
ich gebe aber zu den kollegen in bonn zu
meiner kollegin tina tauß da
[Musik]